[Música]
y
twitter ya no tendrá nuevo dueño y el
multimillonario y lo más retiró su
oferta de 44 mil millones de dólares
para hacerse con la red social más
argumento que la compañía presentó
información engañosa sobre el número de
cuentas falsas la directiva de twitter
anunció que le mandara al magnate
analizamos esta noticia
el gobierno argentino anunció este
viernes la renovación del programa
denominado precios cuidados se trata de
una herramienta para proteger el costo
sobre productos de la canasta básica
familiar desde buenos aires- nuestro
corresponsal nos explica en qué consiste
esta medida con la que el ejecutivo
espera abordar la espiral inflacionaria
para así el batió récord de
deforestación en la selva del amazonas
en los primeros seis meses del año la
destrucción compromete unos tres mil 988
kilómetros cuadrados un 10,6 por ciento
más comparado con el mismo período el
año pasado activistas expertos culpan al
presidente ya y evolucionaron de
retroceder en medidas que protegen el
medio ambiente
momento para repasar las noticias más
destacadas del continente americano mi
nombre es juan pupiales gracias por
estar con nosotros y los más la persona
más rica del mundo según la revista
forbes retiros oferta para comprar la
red social 'twitter' el magnate envió
una carta a la compañía en donde expresa
que cancela el acuerdo por lo que
definió como datos engañosos sobre el
número de cuentas falsas este era un
temor que más ya había expresado desde
twitter aseguran que irán a los
tribunales para hacer respetar el pacto
fijado en 44 mil millones de dólares
previamente hablamos con josé carlos
garcía periodista experto en tecnologías
de la información y comunicación aquí le
preguntamos qué tan difícil es al romper
un acuerdo de estas magnitudes
no es tan fácil con la buenas noches
porque los términos legales y los
alcances desde el punto de vista
financiero son altísimos recordemos que
he ido mostra había ofertado 44 mil
millones de dólares por la compra de
twitter esto en términos prácticos al
salirse pues tiene unas condiciones así
como van cuando hacemos un contrato
a cualquiera de nosotros hay unos
términos que obligan que si alguna de
las partes decide no cumplir con el
contrato puede pagar una cláusula penal
por ello lo que dicen los expertos es
que y los que después tranquilamente va
a poder pagar esa cláusula penal pero
twitter queda en muy malas condiciones
desde el punto de vista financiero es
una compañía que está en bolsa y esto
definitivamente va a afectar muy
fuertemente su acción el presidente de
eeuu yo bailé firmó este viernes una
orden ejecutiva destinada a reforzar el
acceso al aborto ya los anticonceptivos
esto después de que la corte suprema
derogará el fallo de roe versus wade
poniendo fin a 50 años de derecho
constitucional al aborto a nivel federal
en la unión americana la casa blanca
reconoció que el alcance de la medida es
limitado
dos semanas después de que el tribunal
supremo de eeuu derogar el derecho
constitucional al aborto la casa blanca
contraataca el presidente joe biden
firmó una orden ejecutiva destinada a
reforzar el acceso a este procedimiento
wii quien no podemos permitir que un
tribunal supremo fuera de control
trabajando en conjunto con elementos
extremistas del partido republicano
recorte las libertades y nuestra
autonomía personal bailén ha sido
presionado por miembros de su propio
partido para que tomen medidas decisivas
la administración debe continuar
explorando todas las opciones
disponibles para proteger el acceso a la
atención del aborto la abrumadora
mayoría de los estadounidenses se opone
a la decisión de esta corte suprema-
extremista de anular romper sus web la
orden ejecutiva proteger a la privacidad
de las pacientes incluidos los datos
sensibles de la vigilancia digital
relacionados con los servicios de salud
reproductiva también aumenta las
protecciones para las clínicas móviles
que operan en las fronteras estatales y
garantiza el acceso a la medicación para
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
pero la casa blanca reconoció que su
ámbito de actuación es limitado pagarán
la protección de este derecho de las
mujeres de estadounidenses hayden tenía
un mensaje votar en las elecciones de
medio término de noviembre y lograr
mantener la mayoría demócrata en ambas
cámaras del congreso anger state y sólo
estoy exponiendo una noción básica
fundamental la manera más rápida de
restaurar raúl es aprobar una ley
nacional que codifica row la cual
firmará inmediatamente después de su
aprobación en mi escritorio el martes
este viernes un juez de luisiana levantó
el bloqueo judicial que impedía la
entrada en vigor de la prohibición del
aborto en el estado tras la caída de roe
versus wade unos 13 estados de la unión
americana y han implementado duras
restricciones al acceso al aborto y
varios más están considerando sumarse a
las prohibiciones
vamos a argentina porque en este país
sigue preocupando la inflación al alza
que está sacudiendo la economía frente a
este problema el gobierno anunció este
viernes la renovación del programa a
precios cuidados una especie de
referencia para productos de la canasta
básica familiar en medio de esta noticia
la vicepresidenta cristiana fernández
cargó contra martín guzmán quien
renunció el fin de semana como ministro
de economía y lo definió como
irresponsabilidad política
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- a natalio
cosoi quién nos explicó en qué consiste
esta nueva herramienta económica
si se trata de un acuerdo de precios y
programación de aumentos con empresas
para vender productos en supermercados
de rubros como alimentos bebidas
perfumería higiene entre otros no es una
iniciativa nueva nació hace unos nueve
años y se reedita cada tanto en esta
ocasión son casi 950 productos y el
programa se extiende hasta el 7 de
octubre durante esos tres meses los
aumentos promedio que se acordaron no
alcanzan el 10 por ciento y se espera
que eso sea bastante menos que los
aumentos que sufrirán otros productos de
la economía el objetivo de este programa
es por un lado ofrecer a los
consumidores productos a precios
accesibles pero también funcionar como
un ancla para productos similares que no
están dentro del acuerdo de todos modos
precios cuidados no es un programa
exento de problemas por un lado muchas
veces hay faltantes de los productos
acordados y también a veces hay empresas
que han sacado marcas similares
autor del acuerdo ligeramente diferentes
que no tienen precios limitados y que
llegan a las góndolas con los precios
del resto de los productos del mercado
brasil batió un triste récord de
deforestación de la selva del amazonas
en los primeros seis meses del año la
destrucción compromete unos tres mil 988
kilómetros cuadrados de selva un 10,6
por ciento más comparado con las cifras
del mismo período del año pasado
activistas expertos culpan al residente
de jair bolsonaro de retroceder en
medidas que protegen el medio ambiente y
advirtieron del daño irreversible que
eso significa para el ecosistema que
queda expuesto a fenómenos como
incendios forestales y desplazamiento de
fauna debido a la ausencia de vegetación
si tenemos cifras altas de deforestación
es inevitable que también tengamos
cifras altas de incendios y eso es lo
que estamos viendo
así que estamos adelantados un par de
meses antes del pico de la temporada de
quemas en la selva amazónica pero ya
estamos viendo cifras realmente altas
para esta época del año redes también
hay expectativa pero sobre todo
esperanza en las diferentes poblaciones
y ciudades cercanas a la frontera
colombo-venezolana tras el anuncio del
presidente electo de colombia gustavo
petro quien indicó que reabrirá los
cruces entre ambos países y retomará las
relaciones diplomáticas con caracas la
reapertura de la frontera podría
beneficiar a los comerciantes de la zona
y restablecer la vida binacional
es algo que muchos esperan con anhelo la
reapertura de la frontera y la
reactivación del comercio entre colombia
y venezuela una promesa del gobierno
entrante de gustavo petro que llevan
pidiendo desde hace mucho tiempo en
ambos lados de la frontera que estamos
prácticamente a 20 minutos de entrar a
venezuela y pues la verdad sería de suma
importancia y tal vez es vital para
nuestra empresa el tener esa frontera
activa y es que la frontera lleva siete
años cerrada debido a la enemistad entre
las naciones vecinas no obstante el
presidente electo de izquierda gustavo
petro prometió acabar con el bloqueo
normalizar las relaciones entre ambos
países e incluso fomentar el comercio
algo que se espera beneficie la economía
de las dos naciones
hay una complementaria de trabajo de
economía que siempre existe hay una
necesidad y hay productos que aquí se
producen que se necesitan ella y
producen ellas que permitan acá y hay
una cadena binacional es que podrían
complementarse a reestructurarse y
entonces en amores o que sean entre dos
podríamos aportar los otros de los
países y que facilitará la vida de los
ciudadanos venezolanos y colombianos
después de que muchos se vieran
obligados a trabajar en la informalidad
con el cierre de fronteras nos han
afectado a todo el mundo entonces pues
ahora que esté abierta que habrá en la
frontera balas nos volvamos a organizar
otra vez trabaja legalmente como nos
gusta trabajar y
seguir para adelante ahora a los
afectados sólo les queda esperar ya que
aunque el gobierno asume el cargo en
agosto todavía no está claro el momento
de la reapertura
nos despedimos con unas imágenes que
llegan desde chile pero que bien podrían
pertenecer a una película de ciencia
ficción la noche en santiago siguió
iluminada por la entrada en la atmósfera
de un cuerpo rocoso que terminó
consumiendo se dejando este espectacular
estallido de luz fueron estudiantes de
la universidad de concepción los que
identificaron el objeto que seguramente
dejó a más de uno con la boca abierta
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
quédense en la pantalla de france 24 y
también en france 24 punto com
[Música]